oh yeah
[Music]
we discussed this it's time to get black
yell
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
good day good evening good life
it's me Craig Robinson and I'm here to
be your guide through a journey of epic
blackness you know I'm not talking about
my skin which is pretty epic I'm talking
about a new batch of Heroes that are out
in the world taking charge to the spaces
and places you will never imagine I'm
talking about coders CEOs plant whispers
just to name a few
I'm gonna be sort of like your conduit
into these amazing stories and hopefully
they inspire y'all to go out there and
conquer your own calling even if it is
something that will be hard to explain
to your uncle at the family reunion this
year so sit back relax and let's enjoy
together thank you so what I'm not done
yet oh I have to introduce the first
piece before I enjoy this delicious
truffle popcorn okay gotcha
what do Ghana Google and unicorns have
in common
they are all a part of the epic journey
of Idris and ooh dude as a self-taught
computer wunderkind
he started coding at 13 when I was 13
the only decoding I did was looking for
that ring at the bottom of a cereal box
you see Idris is literally out to change
the world through tech and I'm
definitely not gonna be the one to tell
him he can't I already like soccer man -
maybe you can help me make one of those
chess thing so I can dominate my spin
classes Oh No let's see what God and
Google and unicorns have in common
hello Donna Google girl you know we
didn't have a lot of resources we were a
very low-income family and my mom
raising me and she would get these
remote controls from food for less or
she would get them from you don't $0.99
store I remember she used to spank me
all the time because I would like break
the remote control she would buy I would
just always look at the way that circuit
boards were made and the first thing
that I ever programmed was turning a
light on it was a diode a circuit had a
transistor connected to it and it would
just literally send a zero or one state
zeros off one is on and that's when I
was really like I can input a value into
an equation essentially and the output
of it can have an effect on the real
world from a young age I just understood
that no matter what products we ended up
creating there was a story before the
product was created
throughout my life there's been people
that have been very important in shaping
my story and one of those was my Google
colleague who discovered me in the
library 13 years old and showed me that
I could elevate my skills the backstory
of it is I love the library and I was
going to the library every day that was
my virtual reality like a safe haven for
me there I could learn the C sharps and
the C++ is in the objective-c
Java Fortran net 1.0 2.0 one day this
Google designer just happens to come in
and says he recalls seeing this book
online he wants to check out and the
library is like the book should be in
the computer section he goes to the
computer section the book isn't there he
comes back she sends one of her
colleagues with him they couldn't find
the book they both returned to the front
and it dawned on her that there's this
kid that comes in here every single day
and he goes to the same section and just
reads these books and leaves in fact I
think I saw him here today
and so she basically points at the table
I'm at he walks up to me and he's like
if I borrow that book I promise I'll
have it back I was just like here you
can take it and so he takes four steps
away then turns and he's like do you
know what you're reading and I was like
yeah like I just want to learn how to
program as I start to tell him who I am
and where I'm actually from beyond just
being a kid from Compton and moved to
Harbor City being a kid from Ghana that
came here when he was three years old
and how much I wanted to use technology
to really change lives and save lives
he'd offered me an internship at Google
and I was able to go there for a couple
of months and being at one of the
largest companies in the world the
insight that I received has informed
every single decision I've ever made in
my life what that represented to me was
the ability for somebody to really
believe in another person and even from
a young age I just knew that that was a
gift that was the chance that we speak
of being at the right place at the right
time
and in the same way as the library I was
at a Starbucks and just sat there by the
restroom because it's the only section
facing the wall that no one else can see
what I'm doing
I was modifying software because I
realized that I wanted to create a
digital audio workstation for kids in
the hood to be able to make music with
their hands and so I'm just like waving
my hands over the computer screen doing
this Yogi's chain backing against each
other I look up and it was Nipsey Hussle
and then he goes to the front to order a
unicorn Frappuccino for his daughter
that texts one of my friends and I said
you know news he also just walked in I
have a very strong feeling that he's
going to come up to me and my friend was
like oopsy gonna come talk to you so I'm
literally there and I was like he's
gonna come talk to me and that's the
same feeling that I felt the first time
of the global designer and he started
walking my way and I was like I killed
it and then he walks right past me and
goes to the restroom is there for like
20 seconds and it comes right out and
walks past me again he did it four times
the fourth time he comes straight to me
only to find out that he didn't even
need to use the restroom at all and in
the most polite way that anyone is ever
approached me says excuse me sir I'm not
trying to intrude on what you're doing
but I know technology enough that
whatever you're doing is not out if you
wouldn't mind me asking what are you
doing I told him and he just saw it in
that moment and I remember these exact
words he said I want to put you in a
position where the same thing you just
told me you can tell that to everyone I
didn't know where the dialogue
oh I didn't know if he would add me up
he had me up that evening the rest was
history it's really interesting how we
can draw these juxtapositions between
two separate worlds one person that
helped me it was white the other person
that helped me was black a yin and a
yang but these two people had the same
amount of effect that approached me the
same way when we talk about fulfillment
every single person has at least one
time in their life where you really
reflect on your life and then you say
what have I really done and I think I
always knew that my purpose my mission
what I would ultimately leave this earth
doing is fulfilling something greater
than my own existence the boy is bad and
that's bad meaning good for those who
didn't get the slang member like 30
years ago moving right along
what does ma I stand for it it's not
what you think and I definitely know
what you're thinking ma I stands for
movement arts is an organization that
uses movement artistry to inspire and
change the world
while elevating the artistic educational
and social impact of dance and I can't
take credit for the strength of that
statement although I really want to like
like really really bad ma I and its
purpose are the brain children of two
amazing movement artists John bugs from
Miami and lil buck from Memphis these
fellows were nice enough to put together
a bespoke piece for us so without
further ado I present ma I featuring the
poetry of Robin Sanders
[Applause]
[Music]
they are the stories that we tell
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and so they
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and so they did under moonlit skies that
heard their cries for freedom and so
they danced boldly with the librettos of
liberation in their bodies and the earth
beneath them and so they danced freely
on the path paved by their predecessors
waving like the waters that carry their
ancestry frequently flying with no
Wayans Air Force Ones and J's lifted
them amongst the greats they land as
legends their feet
gangster walking on the streets that
birth legacy electric boogaloos G style
and Rocksteady the heroes lived and
loved dance through time in handclaps
finger snaps toe taps buck jumps C C's
hits and pops to the syncopated beat of
djembe drums now reversed in the
Bassnectar of hip hop through hardships
and museums our moving monuments we we
honor them they are the stories that we
tell you their lives blazingly declare
that we are here from generation to
generation gliding and spinning history
bearing the image of greatness we are
now the new ancients
[Music]
[Music]
oh yeah didn't see y'all
watching me robot couldn't help a little
self those fellas are truly inspiring
and Robins poetry is ear candy you can't
get diabetes in your ears can probably
not right
for a final piece I'd like to introduce
y'all to tell me a tme to make sure I
didn't mess up her last name I made a
little game for myself I just think of
her being the final ingredient in a
delicious literary stew like I'm sitting
over the pot and I just need to add a
gimme to it to me is a New York Times
bestselling author who's written two
books and is currently working on the
third I personally am a fan for many
reasons woman grows from the Shire who
like Craig to my girl left a safe job to
pursue her dream I did the same when I
loved teaching to pursue comedy 3 she's
a huge Harry Potter fan me too young I
wonder if told me can write the next
Harry Potter but may carry a brother
maybe helper said to us some time unless
I'll sit back relax and enjoy say with
me y'all told me told me that girl magic
told me told me black girl magic
[Applause]
[Music]
what is magic
a boy casting a spell with a wand a
fairy godmother turning pumpkins into
carriages for this Magi magic is words
it's words that can open minds words
that can lift Souls words that can
change the world forever
but a lot has to happen before that
magic can work each act is a battle
every word and attack every story award
[Music]
to cast this magic the young Magi must
first gather her inspiration she must
take the seeds of a story buried deep in
her mind and make it come alive before
her eyes
[Music]
it's like I don't even know if this
section should be in the book I don't
think she would do that I don't feel
like that feels true to her character it
doesn't feel right I appreciate the
suggestion like I get what you're saying
but that doesn't change who she is as a
person okay okay you can go thank you
once all the magi x' ideas are out she
must put them together to create her
magic she must consider what character
arcs are most dynamic what plot points
are most exciting
what world building is most powerful
what fees she must reflect she must
refine the bones of the story until she
has something that makes sense then she
must go to work the Magi must write
again and again never stopping
never letting up
[Music]
she must create hundreds of pages burn
those pages and then write again
she must fight the words until the magic
can come alive
but when the magi work is done her magic
is powerful it spreads around the world
it takes root in heart after heart
it empowers those who feel it's fresh
calling them to cast their own magic and
it lives forever
[Music]
because powerful magic
never dies
[Music]
well that about does it for today's
episode y'all damn that was fun
educational and eye-opening I hope you
feel the same don't forget to tune into
next week's episode where we'll do it
again with three new friends not gonna
get out of here and hit the library then
working my dance moves and then put some
hours in on my next well first novel I
mean I've written children's books but I
got to get some longer reformed
intellectual property poppin 2020 don't
forget to listen to the podcast where we
dive even deeper into our stories check
it out on I heart or wherever you get
your podcast fix and as always don't be
afraid to find what you love share with
the world and scream from the
mountaintop your attention please
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello to Hulu and watch the full
episodes of your attention please
hosted by yours truly I promise your
little mouths will be blown when you see
what we cooked up amazing stories about
powerful new heroes and black culture
out there killing it in spaces and
places you won't even see coming so go
check it out and let us know what you
think in the comments section I'll be
waiting and as always don't forget to
Like and subscribe to this channel later